ich hab mich unglaublich aufgeregt über
das was helge braun nicht von sich
gegeben hat sondern falsch punkten
infiziert hat und zwar hat er am 24 juli
dieses jahres gesagt wenn delta sich so
weiterentwickelt und wenn die impfquote
so bleibt dann haben wir in neun wochen
eine instanz von
850 ja heute ist's was helge braun
gemeint hat und wir haben eine instanz
von 70 das haben wir bei bild
angeprangert und helge braun hat gesagt
nein moment mal das war gar keine
falsche prognose in dem sinne denn es
gehe ja immer darum sozusagen eine
warnung auszusprechen eine horror
prognose zu geben um dann nicht auf 850
zu kommen ich finde den dieser debatte
zeigt sich der ganze wahnsinn dieser
corona politik und die ganze absurdität
und auch die ganze verlogenheit denn am
ende ist es so politiker wollen uns
jetzt erzählen dass sie immer richtig
liegen denn wenn sie eine falsche
prognose machen und am ende ist viel
geringer wird dann haben wir braven
bürger reagiert ich finde das empörend
und wir brauchen dringend eine debatte
über diese falschen prognosen
ich finds ja herzerwärmend also die so
empören kannst über helge braun weil die
man reden muss man zurück ist ja auch
vor monaten irgendwann wenn alle ein
empfang gebot haben dann werden den
krone maßmann fragen also wenn jeder
erwachsene ist ob es verstanden
zumindest ein empfang geburt bekommen
hat und das wahrnehmen konnte dann
werden die maßnahmen fallen und dann war
helge braun hier bei euch im studio und
ich glaube dann waren seine ausreden
warum es nicht passiert es unter anderem
dass kinder ja noch keine angebote
bekommen hätten also in diesem sinne mit
das ist es ja jetzt überhaupt nichts
neues aber was ich spannend findet ist
ja dass das thema corona abgesehen von
manchen wollen sie im spricht oder nicht
fragen im 3l im wahlkampf nicht
vorkommen das thema also eigentlich weiß
noch nicht wenn man wirklich wählen soll
wenn man eigentlich wenn man keinen
lockdown will die fdp könnte das thema
finde ich viel mehr besetzen also man
dass sie wollen die freiheitspartei sein
dass sie da immer nur sehr zögerlich
verstehe ich gar geht ja schon aber da
es ja da wird ja oft wohnen ganz vielen
in der partei als er außenstehender was
sagt er jetzt schon wieder man gesehen
was sie gar nicht verstehen weil er
finde ich sehr auf den punkt trifft das
könnte die fdp es so aus aber liegt es
daran dass die fdp vielleicht sorge hat
im herbst am ende der regierung zu
sitzen und dann irgendein lockdown mit
beschließen zu müssen ich meine man
stelle sich mal vor man schaut sich um
bin auf der welt und da kann man gut
erkennen was vielleicht zumindest an
politischer diskussion wieder bei uns
droht bei den usa wo die masken pflicht
schon abgeschafft und offiziere zum
bestimmten staaten wieder eingeführt
auch in österreich geht es hin und her
also wer weiß vielleicht hat die fdp
angst in der regierung zu sein und dann
am ende irgendwann das beschließen zu
müssen berichtete stimmt aber sie haben
ja versprochen dass es keine
steuererhöhungen geben und sollten sie
die ampelkoalition eingehen wird auch
das schwierig na also es stimmt schon
aber ich hätte mir schon gedacht dass
man gerade im wahlkampf irgendwie dass
sein wolfgang kubicki also auch im
winter und der hat ja schon im winter
daraufhin gewesen mit den schulen mit
den kindern also ich muss sagen kubicki
habe ich wirklich nur in erinnerung ob
im januar hier bei uns bei bild live im
februar/märz er dir immer auf die
grundrechte immer auf die kinder
hingewiesen ich finde ich schon aber er
will ja auch kein minister werden und
helge braun so düster bleiben
wahrscheinlich oder
ausgeschlossen wenn es daran aber man
muss man die trial parteien sind ja ein
bisschen als die lektoren parteien
gebrandet die fdp hat sich schon anders
positionieren auf höhe
macht das nicht so klar dass ich es
machen können ich glaube trotzdem dass
wir nach der bundestagswahl recht
schnell eine neue politik in dieser
hinsicht kriegen vor allen dingen weil
auch aus der ärzteschaft dann aus der
wissenschaft jetzt immer lautere signale
kommen wir dürfen uns nur nicht freedom
day nennen weil der freedom in
deutschland nicht so eine große lobby
hat es muss wahrscheinlich der
sicherheitstag bei uns
irgendwann hatten die briten in freedom
day das war doch zwei monate und juni
geschrieben so war das würde in
deutschland halt niemals passieren und
eben nicht nur weil nicht die maßnahme
nicht vereinbart dass man weil wir
niemals eine freiheitstag vereinen
würden bald um gottes willen was ist
freiheit ja sicherheitstag wer wirklich
in feiern ist ganz schön
aber eigentlich können das so frei wir
haben zwei drittel sind geimpft es gibt
kein ernstes problem weil das
vitalisierung mehr hätten wir das vor
einem jahr so gedacht wer mir doch happy
gewesen und ein land nach dem anderen
geht jetzt raus und will zurück in die
freiheit die deutschland sind mit
freiheit immer ein bisschen reagierend
das ist seit jahrhunderten aber
wir hätten da ich nehme mal an bis
weihnachten sich ja nicht selbst
kritischer das verstehe nicht warum uns
und helge braun sagen ja nun also gar
keine falsch prognose denn 850 das wäre
ja passiert wenn ich nicht gewarnt hätte
also erholsamer ich bin entsetzt dass
sie jetzt die begriffe politiker und
selbstkritik noch in einen im gleichen
satz bringt das zeigt dass sie noch
völlig idealistische vorstellen und
warum politiker habe ich bin selber auch
politikern und ich kann ihnen sagen
politik haben sich noch nie selbst nicht
durch zu selbstkritik in der lage ich
bin selbstverständlich die löbliche
einzige ausnahme sind will analysten ich
ja auch nicht so 100 und journalisten
sind in der regel noch empfindlicher als
politiker aber ich muss hier
uneingeschränkt paul ronzheimer rich
geben also was da abgeht mit diesen
fehlprognosen und zwar von anfang an
diese pandemie ist das geht auf keine
kuhhaut und das bestürzende besteht ja
darin dass diese fälle prognostiker
dieter mund voll daneben gehauen haben
mit ihrem panikorchester dass keiner von
denen für seine verstoßen gerade stellen
muss die können einfach weiter prognos
die ziehen die werden immer noch
eingeladen die welt denen hört man immer
noch zu die erzählen und sie nach dem
anderen und können und sagen wir stehen
für die wissenschaft und jeder der
dagegen ist natürlich ein alter hut ist
ein verrückter ist wie ein verschwörungs
bühne dabei sind eigentlich gab die
verrückten sind diese prognostik die
solche unglaublichen
monströsen welt prognos nachsehen aber
ich sehe in dieser runde hat sicher die
heiterkeit verbreitet wir haben auch
gelernt mit diesem apokalyptischen
szenarien die nie eintreten umzugehen
und die quasi richtig einzuordnen sich
in unserem wälder und begangen
habe
nicht wirklich wir müssen die
bevölkerung ernst nehmen nämlich mich
einige wie die macht übertrage ich sehe
keinen sinn mehr in sich trugen tragen
muss ich bin doch ich möchte diese
chance maßgeblich bestimmten einigen wir
uns darauf fertig
ausnahmezustand beendet nikolov die
apokalypse wird beendet die apokalypse
und beginnen wieder mit einem normalen
leben hier einfach erkennt die mehrheit
stimmung im land die politik macht das
ja deswegen weil sie weiß dass die
mehrheit stimmung freiheits kritisch ist
als hier sei das land der rauchmelder
deutschland hat mehr drauf als die
gesamte restliche welt zusammen und in
diesem land misst durchsaniert ich jetzt
ist daraus der radarfallen wir haben die
höchste dichte an rad fahren also wie
sie dahin aus
wenn man auf österreich schaut zum
beispiel dass man immer die dann
vorangegangen sind und dann haben sie
doch wieder angst bekommen also das war
auch ich habe gott sind die drei länder
perspektive und beobachte man alle drei
irgendwie und das ist wirklich immer so
dass die schweiz irgendwie noch immer
als wenn man sich vorstellt die selbst
sichersten freiheitsliebenden ankommt
österreich und dann kommt deutschland
und es ist wirklich immer in diesen
kreis und ja es stimmt aber wenn jetzt
beide deine betrachter deutschland und
österreich war österreich immer ein
bisschen vorsichtiger und sozusagen also
immer ein bisschen mehr freiheit und sie
haben jetzt echt gar keine anderen werte
als wir es stimmt schon dass jetzt auch
wieder überlegt wird wo wir was die
debatte um zweig und sogar 1 gegen läuft
genauso wie in deutschland und deswegen
befürchte dass es im winter eben nicht
vorbei sein der flüchtende also ich
glaube nicht dass wird das gegessen ist
ende jahr wieder nach oder also die
kinder können laut aussagen von jens
spahn heute vermutlich erst im ersten
quartal des nächsten jahres geimpft
werden bis dahin geht das schuljahr roja
durch bis weihnacht aber für wir wollen
die kinder nicht impfen lassen
da sind doch automatisch warum sollen
die kinder überhaupt wenn ich weise
können wir uns weitergeben aber langsam
muss ich sagen ich verstehe viele der
diskussion nicht mehr erreicht ich
glaube man muss auch einfach mal sagen
es reicht und wir haben auch schon eine
schwierige stimmung in diesem land ich
meine immer wer bei schwerer stimme hat
sollten also was ich interessant war bei
der debatte um zwang oder nichts wagen
war die entwicklung in frankreich das
muss man ja mal sagen immer noch einmal
große großes risiko eingegangen ja also
hat sich diesem gestellt und hat gesagt
der den verpflichtenden passt zum
beispiel wenn man zur arbeit will muss
man vorzeigen dass man geimpft ist also
hat sozusagen die hürden aufgebaut und
er wurde da extrem kritisiert dafür dass
er sozusagen
freiheitsrechte einschränkt für
diejenigen die nicht geimpft sind und
zack impfquote um fast 20 prozent das
ist schon auch eine interessante
entwicklung also ich hätte zum beispiel
nicht erwartet dass dieser zwang gerade
in frankreich wo man die gelb westen
kennen die leute schnell auf die straße
gehen dass gerade in so einem land das
dann plötzlich funktioniert
für die menschen gemacht wurden schon
ich möchte noch etwas positives über
deutschland sorgen und freiheit auch
wenn aktuell deutschland nicht puncto
corona das freiheitliche land aus der
schweiz zum beispiel wir abnehmen auch
diese zweiteilung der gesellschaft in
zertifizierte schweizer und nicht
zertifizierte schweizer die vom sozialen
leben ausgeschlossen werden in
deutschland ist das noch nicht in dieser
drakonischen schärfe umgesetzt wurden da
lob ich mir deutschland und ich lasse
mir die hoffnung nicht glauben dass die
freiheit und das freiheits bewusstsein
seien in deutschland wach ist als
wolfram weimer aus langer leidensweg
erfahren hier sehr überzeugend dargelegt
[Musik]